[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day
it's the ten-year anniversary of
Christopher Nolan's The Dark Knight the
film of course where Heath Ledger made
his iconic performance of the Joker
to celebrate the 10 year anniversary
they're re-releasing it in IMAX 70
millimeter
I'm excited are you guys excited yeah
great well you guys fans at the Dark
Knight when it came out yeah scared like
I still find the Joker so scary
he's so scary I think he's so cool one
of the things that The Washington Post
was writing is that the Joker Heath
Ledger's The Joker was the og internet
troll that he kind of heralded in this
era of modern internet trolls because
he's anonymous yeah and he laughs at
other peoples expense do you think
that's a stretch or do you think there's
something that huge stretch okay it's a
total stretch I kind of jumped in there
that was a little hot but I just think
that that's like totally ridiculous that
a movie character assured in people
being coming around anyway I think
that's what the article saying I think
it's like the article captured like a
like the seed of a sentiment that I
don't think the Joker influenced trolls
but it's like the Joker was a character
that somehow like captured this idea
that trolls yes I think the idea of like
doing it for the lulz
or as Alfred the butler would say some
people just like to watch the world but
the segments taking a turn
yeah because I think the Washington Post
article talked about how at the time it
seemed like he was talking about the
Bush administration like that and now if
we look at it it feels like instead what
it was commenting on is like this kind
of new generation of people never
apologizing just being delighted by
people's misery
yes and it's like the why so serious is
like you mad bro it's exact the article
said that I will say I think Keith
ledger is way too hot to be an internet
troll okay imagine just a troll just
like a fat dude in a basement drinking
Mountain Dew that's like essentially
what Trump says these people that like
do things online we want them to be like
amorphous blobs that live in like off
their parents and are just disgusting
and like just eat like gross food all
day but I really think that they're just
like I think anybody here could be an
internet troll and maybe some of them
are beautiful Australians who are taken
from us before their time true yes he's
like I got it Nate Duran was talking
about Heath Ledger hashtag Dortmund does
yeah I remember I saw him in what was it
10 Things I Hate About You
right yeah whoo I was like cool whatever
you do and I don't like I am so scared
all the time and so I don't like scary
movies but I was like I'm going to see
The Dark Knight because I think he's a
dream man I don't think I've ever heard
anyone describe like a superhero movie
as a scary movie I don't think of it as
like a horror or at the book yeah the
book yeah I got really far so Comic Con
is actually happening this weekend and
our very own Jordan Mendoza is gonna be
there with Chris cotton Jordan what are
you excited about it come okay I'm
excited about Riverdale Cass is gonna be
there which doesn't seem like the most
comic-con thing actually no Archie
comics yes of course
brilliant and let's see venom I'm so
excited about that Tom Hardy Bane
that's a little Yoda keep working on it
work on it with your seat partner on the
flight okay you guys excited to go to
somewhere besides comic-con yeah yeah
what are you doing this weekend oh this
weekend
[Laughter]
hey Jordan I want to put you on the spot
one more time it's time for YouTube
shout out I think I want to hear you do
this shout out but in your best
Joker impression I did a pretty perfect
Alfred earlier it was really good I
thought this was gonna devolve into just
doing that yeah okay wait there got so
quiet all right this is from the gremlin
Smurf Smurf so many white people say
that say the company again in normal
voice so many white people and they're
talking about the the cast on the show
okay right right I think I think later
he clarified yes so could you respond to
that I respond well I respond rather
responded to them with a list of all the
different our ethnicities Chris and I
non-white I'm Asian Chris is black but
Chris not here today for this will be a
comic-con Chris will be at Comic Con
Natasha is Russian which as an Asian
I've grant her full Asian powers Ryan is
Lebanese Hanna classic Americana
Americana let's do a different thing
right now
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah Dickinson and this is
cheers to you where I'm kicking off my
first round of the weekend by cheering
to all the people and stories that
encouraged me to drink cheers to you
model on the runway who breastfed our
baby it's good to know some of you out
there eating cheers to you women who
bought the new crock heels now you can
look sexy eating those nachos alone
cheers to McDonald's for pulling salads
from your menu after a parasite outbreak
I'm sad to see them go honestly I love
to eat McDonald's and drop a few lbs
[Laughter]
cheers you mega Markel providing certain
royal rules difficult to understand
can't be that hard maybe it just need a
little slap and tickle to throw a
spanner in the works cheers to you Paris
Hilton for calling Lindsay Lohan a
pathological liar but are you trying to
point the finger are you just offering a
bump of cocaine cheers you woman who bit
off another woman's nose when asked to
leave her house bolt may I suggest my
own subtle tactics of pretending to be
asleep or faking a pregnancy
cheers to Matt Lauer for losing your
horse farm in your divorce settlement if
only you had a way to lock that date
all right Cheers glad we could do this
yeah me too hi welcome to game boys
we're gonna be playing Monopoly one turn
at a time every day until we complete
the game or until they fire us
so to begin since today's our first day
each player gets the same amount of
money a practice also known as socialism
thank you now it's time to select our
piece
I'm gonna go with this little
Tyrannosaurus Rex he's replacing the
thimble piece but I like to think that
this little guy may be swallowed a few
thimbles and that's why he's here at the
Monopoly board with us today I'm gonna
choose this little penguin because I
like to think this little guy swallowed
a few thimbles on his way to the
Monopoly board and that's why he's here
with us today
[Music]
Connecticut Avenue I'll buy that nice
one
[Music]
one two three four five six seven
10:11 st. Charles place I'm gonna go for
it
see you next time I'm Michael Carmichael
Carmichael Carmichael thanks for
watching today's episode I'm Marc okay
I'm Michael we'll see you next time or
over don't
[Music]
you